three thanks thanks for the introduction
and and thanks to the organizers for the
invitation to this really really
interesting workshop what I will be
presenting is first of all can you hear
me lo ok I have some echo but if you can
hear me fine so this is during work with
Angie Moravsky who's at Warwick and
actually believe Angie was here I am in
the previous in the previous workshop
about a month ago and myself so what I
will be talking about is some some
reason work we did on linear is a bit so
what is linear ability it's it's a
correctness criterion for programs like
or libraries if you like in the context
of programming languages any particular
libraries that you can assume that we
assume that they are called concurrently
so many clients or many threads maybe
call in a library and then if you look
at the behavior of fourth year of your
program or your library then it gets it
gets more involved because of all these
different threads and how they
communicate and how actually they affect
for example the common state that the
library may have and in particular the
criterion is used well one uses to show
that a specific piece of code that you
note here is this to a specification
that you would like in general these
theories apply applicable to first of
the programs i will say what that means
but basically means you have libraries
where for example do computations from
integers to integers like that's what i
mean by first older and what and one
antenna i did is we we took some idea
that we already knew from game semantics
and applied in this setting in order to
extend the know this notion to hire the
programs
I'll start with some some picture of the
order of the setting so I will assume
now we have so this is code well I mean
it's easy yeah well it's an abstraction
so this L is a library and this case is
a client and the client has some
programs some methods that they run in
parallel in 12 mm and when they run they
use some methods from the library but
the mat let's have typed theta so this
theta is a set that says for example if
my library is a Q theta will have two
methods and Q which goes from int to
void which means I give you an integer
and you NQ it or DQ so I called the Q
and I get back the end of the queue
right so that's that's the interaction
okay and now we want to look at the the
threat like the traces or the histories
if you like that we can produce by this
simple scenario we have enqueue and
dequeue so let's see here is a diagram
of what behaviors we can have so time
goes from left to right yep and then
here i have tried so this is one thread
the second third and the third thread
and the beginning we have the first
thread calls enqueue it was 21 the value
1 and the library returns this is okay i
yank you did and then the second thread
says okay now 12 and q2 and then the
library return and then the third thread
when it calls DQ and this is a queue
since this is a cube we would like what
the client returns to be 1 because 1 is
the first thing in the queue okay
now we can see this is a very simple
setting because there is a clear
distinction of working start and end
between different threads but I can make
more complicated I can say okay suppose
that this while this is in queuing
another call to ank you has has been
issued and this is still a [ __ ]
behavior because okay the two anchors
happen concurrently so it may be that
this one finishes first so therefore
when we did you would get that back and
actually it could even be like that that
these things happen concurrently and
although this one returns first it
actually is the case that this one was
enqueued first just that the return
action was was delayed to come out but
it's indeed this guy who was in cube
first and therefore when we dequeue you
get back that and i can make it even
like that i can say oh well even if i
call this first and the second it may
very well be that this guy is thank you
first so when i DQ i get one back okay
what I would I shouldn't be able to say
is that I call NQ of to these returns I
call in q1 this returns but then when I
did you get one because here there is
this a clear distinction that ok this
guy finished and then this one was
called so it better be that too was
ranked it first so we see that some
behaviors were allow some behaviors we
don't allow we wouldn't like to allow
and this is what the criteria now I'm
going to be introducing next is supposed
to capture so the criteria is called
Lena's ability and it says well I
behavior is correct if it follows a
given specification that I have so this
we skip specification I would have for a
key would be if you ank you and then you
dig and UD q well you should the accuser
always the top of the first element of
the queue but you can so it's a behavior
is correct if it's it follows a given
specification modulo some reordering so
factions and the others have to do with
internal delays that you have one
library compute this notion has been
reduced in the 90s this paper and by now
it's a standard criteria for a
concurrent programs so if i went back
here I had this behavior at the begin
and we can see that this is sequential
in a sense of things happen in sequence
there's no concurrency when this
finishes then the next goal is is
afterwards and then there's here they
stick they're separated so i can say
okay this is a correct specification and
now excuse me this is also correct
because if i swap these two events i
arrived here and I know that this is
correct okay so I start from this
specification and I want to check this
correct night and say i can assume that
these things can be i can swap them
because they happen concurrently so it
may be that this one fringes because
before this one is this code and
therefore this one is correct or like if
i have this situation i can say okay
maybe I can exchange these two and I
know that this is good because I can
exchange the game and reach a value
specification but here there's no reason
I can make reasonably because if I the
order these two events I start from
something that was sequential in a big I
imposed it to be concurrent
so we would say that so suppose now we
have what I was describing before I
would like to make it a bit more formal
so we have a setting of histories of
observable actions and actions were this
course and returns i was i was having in
the diagrams and i will say i say that
actions a and b can be transposed if
they appear in different threads and
they're not of the form editor and
followed by a code so in a sense they're
not sequential is not that we can
distinguish that something returned in
something else was called if not that is
not the case that I'm allowed to
transpose them we say that a history h1
Lee another stage two if we can get from
h1 to h2 by using these transpositions
so while i was showing before with legal
tours positions i could do in histories
okay and then I if I have a library then
I can say that the library is really
nervous with some specification if every
history in the library can be can
linearized to another history that is
inside the specification and the
specification is is given in set of
sequential histories where I have a call
followed by later and how the call for
the very term and we can see why this is
why we want to write our specifications
like that we want to do this because
these are sequential histories and we
can we can reason more more easily about
go back to my example I had this and
when I show you said okay stop is that
this is correct because when it's a
sequential program innocent so this is
good as a specification and then I use
this as it as in order to judge what the
other histories are legal okay
ok
and then when I was talking about legal
transpositions I was maybe a bit vague I
mean maybe there is some intuition that
I i was able to to pass on to pass you
but actually this can be made very
precise we can say that a library l
linearized another library l prime which
means every history in one can be
linearized occasioned another we can
prove that if this happens then what
this is this is a sound criteria in the
sense that L is an approximation of L
prime observational and because this was
so did these people are quite recently
observation approximation means that if
I put any client k and i'll link it with
l then this composed program terminates
the sound value equal terms and value
then this composed program here we
terminated the same value actually here
i don't even need to say the value just
if it terminates is enough so in a sense
the client cannot have more behaviors
here cannot observe more behaviors in el
Daniel prime and that's what makes the
reasonable the reasoning sound okay
um
now I want to extend this to hire other
libraries and now the settings becomes a
bit more complicated I will have a
library here l and I will have a client
again and now the library provides this
methods theta prime so remember these
are method names and I also have other
types but it also depends on some other
methods theta for the ones in for which
it doesn't have implementation and it
used at third library a parameter
library where this parameter library
provides implementation for this method
CL so there are three place if you like
here and they exchange actions between
them the client is the one who starts
the computation by distance here and the
client can also directly contact the
parameter library by possibly by this
other method Sita double Prime so what
we would like to do to do is to look
into the interactions we have here and
come up with a notion of linear ability
that generalizes the previous the
previous notion and it's also sound okay
so
and actually this is something that has
been examined before but only for the
first order case so we're all the
methods are from int to int in the
harder case we'll have live we have
methods that receive other methods as
input and can receive other method can
produce other meta set outputs but the
First Circuit order case was done by by
these people and actually quite recently
which is in that this were that work
instigated are actually our work okay so
to show what they this setting is more
complicated or more elaborate I will
have this will demonstrate this side of
the cube where the enqueue we enqueue
methods so unq methods of type int arrow
int and when Wendy you Dicky you get
back integers another trick is the
following you given method you in queue
it you give another method you include
you have your yo-yo little Q of methods
and then when you asked to DQ you Dickie
Lee like the first element the first
method and you apply a number to it and
this number comes from a counter that
you keep internal so for example if I
ank you in one and then I am too and
then I called Vic you then dig you will
call say m1 the counter is one and when
m1 returns I will return what m1
returned if I if I was called to DQ
again i would call em to with value 2
and so on this is clear so what why I am
presenting this because now if you
remember before we had calls and returns
and the client was calling the the
library was returning and that was all
but not have more complicated I have
added more behaviors which was at this
point the client calls and the library
calls again she calls back to the client
so in terms of game semantics well what
we have here is again between two
players the client in the library and
they exchange this action so this moves
between them
particularly when the client wants to DQ
I take the method that i have in my in
my queue but the method comes from the
client it in order to find out what the
value it is for one I have to call back
to be to the client and not only that I
have I can make it even more complicated
I can say well I i NQ m1 and m2 and then
when I'm called to DQ I call em one with
one so now it's the client I'm calling
back to the client the client says well
in order to return I will call back and
called eat you again and then the lab
reduce our girl take then what I have in
my in my queue which is m2 and apply to
to it and this is cause back to the
client that the client would reply so
the game gets more complicated
so in general what happens is I have
these calls issued by the client and the
client gives methods as inputs and then
the library can call back this method it
gets a bit more elaborate than before so
in particular method called not be
followed by three time because I have
the call followed by another call and
everybody can issue codes and returns
the client the library and also the
parameter library that I didn't include
the previous examples and not only that
but before when I was calling a
returning the methods were given in the
type in the interface I had NQ in DQ now
have all these other methods that appear
out of well was not out of thin air but
appeared during the interaction and they
can be cold and return again and and
when you see at this this at first it
may look very difficult to reason about
this but actually this is exactly what
what what the field of game semantics
for full program does for you this
exchange of moves is exactly what gave
semantics model incidentally it this
setting is not even clear what
sequential histories are before
sequential kid stories were calls
followed by returns but here if we take
this approach it would be very
restrictive because in some scenarios
there's nowhere you can get a call
followed by its return so this is a this
is a one slide presentation of game
semantics so it's more propaganda rather
than me explaining in very properly but
it's a theory where we actually explain
higher the programs in a way that is
both operational aiding denotational in
particular when you have a program you
model is computation as a two-player
game between the program which is the
proponent of the game or P and an
opponent which is the environment where
this the program sits inside so the
environment calls your function the the
program the program computes internally
and it may return so produce a return
move or it may need to call him a
function of the environment so it will
call back and this this exchange of
course the returns is called
moves and the interactions the formal
interactions are the plays of the game
and programs are modular strategies for
the play that models a program and this
has a very nice denotational
presentation you can compose strategies
and you can define categories of games
and then starting from simple
ingredients model whole programming
languages and paneer this goes back to
the 97 and the end the work of Samsung
and Adam and Pasquale but and since I
mean and also and so it started from
like languages like PCF and and and
idealized algo en in in in recent years
it has moved to languages like ml or
Java what you achieve with game is that
you have this denotational model body
also has because of the you have plays
you also have intention information and
the level of interment internet into
intentionality have is is optimal in the
sense that you can show that you don't
have any extra information in it and
this is this you can show by full
abstraction say that before the
behaviors are having my model are
exactly those that are observable and in
this work actually we use another an
approach where you present the model
completely operationally using traces
and Tre semantics and trace them antics
for open programs but is equivalent to
do the traditional game semantics
presentation okay so going back to my to
my scenario I have L the library l and
then I want to link it in this in this
setting so say well I'll take L I
composite with L prime and then I link
this composition to this client here and
then I will model this as a game where
the proponent is the library and the
opponent is the combination of these two
guys
ok
or to give you very quickly what the
syntax is it doesn't really matter we
could have used the same city for
different syntax but we needed some
syntax to prove a theory eventually so
we have libraries and the libraries have
methods abstract and public and then you
define your methods and then you say
here are the definitions of my methods
so a method M has this body i also have
references i can say the reference are
has this value initially or this value
and then the method body scan will come
from from my functional language with
references in this case and then clients
are just compositions of of terms and
then the type that i have in this
language are just simply the simple
types of our unit integers and using
products as well
and our history suppose I have theta
theta prime which are sets of methods
with types so history is a sequence of
pairs like this where T is a thread
identifier and Asian action so the
actions are the recall or a return of
the method M + V some value that comes
from the previous syntax and down here i
also have an index which says which
player played this either opponent or
proponent and and i have some conditions
with used results I allow for example
for this thread TI a course and returns
have to be well-matched when you return
you return to the last method that was
called and it hasn't been answered yet
and the two players alternate for
example and also have some some
conditions I say if you want to call a
method you'd better be introduced first
so you might appear either in the types
or somebody played before you I know you
sleepy cannot call its own methods only
the methods at the other plate
introduced and so forth these are just
conditions that allow me to formulate
when well the place is well-formed like
that is a possibility that account like
the scenario like that it's an area like
the previous one can't reduce you game
semantics things for their take match
yes it is like standard game semantics
but the pointer the pointer structure
has been replaced by method names it's
like a concrete nominal representation
of four games it's interesting because I
mean it's also interesting because this
is a very operational but it's also make
in it makes sense to people that have
worked on operational methods whereas
the pointer structure maybe it's more
it's more denotational okay so going
back to our examples I had this disc you
with thank you in DQ I like this
interaction and other history correspond
to this one is there is a call to
enqueue in the first in the first thread
there's a call to enqueue the second
thread this then returned and then there
is a call of DQ the third thread and
this returns and then I had this other
example where with the high-order queue
and now what I have is I ank you a
method on third one I Yankee method on
32 and this return and then there is a
DQ 33 and this then issues a column and
1m one returns and a dick irritate the
same value like I make this even more
complicated in to do include so this was
the lab real goes from theta theta prime
previously see that was empty but I can
say okay there is a parameter library
here that provides me foo method that
goes from voi to int and then what I
want to say is I call I ank it twice and
when I want to DQ I call this extra
function and this gives me a value now
call the the method that i have in my in
my queue with this value so I make this
amit so in this case this method this
call and return it's easy to the
parameter library ok ok and I wanted to
find the linear built in this context
and the criteria is quite it's quite
simple to formulate so we'll say that
these two actions can be transposed if
and only fill out the form of the
following form they're on different
threads TT Prime and this guy here is an
all-action so it belongs to the opponent
so this happens then I can say that the
opponent actually answered later and
dually I can dispose this too if this
action on the right is a pee it's a pee
action you can go on the left I mean
this look like equivalent but obviously
here this also applies you have 0 0 and
this applies you have PP
and then the definition is as before I
say that 81 linearized ways to if we can
get from h1 to h2 by this trans position
and also what does it mean for a library
to linearize to specification where if
every history in the library can be
linearized the history in the
specification and almost as a by-product
also get a definition of what does it
mean for the history to be sequential
well in just those histories where every
opponent movies or opponent action is
followed by a pee action on the same
thread so before it was a call followed
by the time and I was an opponent action
by P action because obviously p can be
answered by calling again okay
so this is a definition we reduced let's
see how this works so this is the
relation is p.o the way i read this is
that it means that P moves can only
always move to the left and almost got
always move to the right so if this was
the initial example we had with the
first order q so we had this and I
kosaka this move here it's a P move so
according to this mnemonic he can be
moved to the left so I can move it there
and give this one and I can see that
this one is correct because it's a
question history so I enqueue 1i and q2
and then I DQ 1 so then I circuit this
history is correct but then I had this
other history which I said it wasn't
correct and I can see that in this one I
cannot do any moves because I have these
batters hear of a pea move followed by a
gnome IP action followed by an
all-action so when you have this there's
no way you can transpose so basically
you can move it to the left or to the
right but you have a peel it's it's
fixed so this is incorrect because i
cannot transpose it to something that
would make sense and if i go to the
higher order example where i had these
methods but again i have this move here
this is a pea movie can we move to the
left and i can get this that is correct
because i think um 1 and Q 2 and then I
call DQ n 1 again but also i can assume
that this have this history where am i
start by inking and one then m 2 and
then when i DQ i actually dqm to and
basically what happens is that these two
moves here are concurrent and this is a
no move so you can be transposed to the
right and this is this system of
something sequential that also is this
correct ok ok and in this higher the
queue that i showed before ok i won't go
through the details but the behaviors
you can get a very complicated and if
you want to write a specification for it
it's very difficult if you want to come
to consider all possible interleaving
but within
five but with this criterion it suffices
to consider check myself histories and
in fact for sequential histories were
every so every move is followed every
all movies followed by P move in the
same thread I can actually write down a
specification that ok looks complicated
but I can't write it down so this this
helps in also writing down
specifications ok why is this correct so
the correctness the correctness criteria
for you is a painting this case would be
approximation as in the first-order case
we want to say that if l1 linear is well
too then for every context where I can
put a one the combined they will
terminate implies that the combined
thing for them to alternate this and
this actually done composition so i use
compositionality in-game semantics and
the argument at least at this high level
is it's quite simple if we define the
semantics for so the semantic bracket
gives semantics for libraries and
contacts so if you put a library here it
will produce its history they've put a
context here it will prove produce the
histories that the context good are
produced and then we simply show well we
have to show that if you link a library
into a specific context l prime k then
the behaviors you get are equivalent if
you somatically composed the semantics
of the context to the semantics of the
library now to show that these
transpositions you did to caitlin's
ability are correct well suffices to
show that so here you do the strands
positions this oh this Bo if you do
transposition started for library l and
you have that the library the the
context you can post can is actually
closed under the dual transposition then
then this is enough because it means
that whatever l one can compose to for
l2 there is there is the cottage
something that I got can compose and
produce the same result so basically if
we take the dual relation of p 0 so the
door riddle a she would be instead of
moving p moves on the left you would
move almost on the left and peoples of
the right we can actually prove that the
semantics 4404 context of a library
cisco is closed under this this duel
notion so therefore we somehow get this
soundness for free and in fact this this
disclosure I was talking about like
closed under the dual of this this
relation it's exactly the notion of data
it's exactly the conditions you have in
Game semantics for concurrent programs
where you proved that your strategies
are saturated under this what they need
to be saturated under this relation in
order to get full abstraction and this
is something that had been done before
it just we applied in this new setting
yes the closure property actually is
very is is done it's aight said like 5
line argument because the the semantics
is done is defined operationally so you
want to say that if i have AP move and
then it's followed by another p move
then i can transpose them and you use
you use simple ideas like you just look
at this amount we say okay well actually
the two threads in order for them to
synchronize they need to access a store
but these specific in this specific
moves i can assume that they first did
the axis of the store and then the last
not happen after so you can use very
simple tricks to show that you can
transpose mu so the hardness then the i
mean in this argument had this busy
showing that compositionality because
you define the model operationally so
composition has been has to be a theorem
rather than than a definition it becomes
actually quite difficult and we use by
simulation techniques to show that
compositionality works okay and lastly
there is a special case of the scenario
which is game again again came from this
paper which is well what happens if the
two opponents hear the cry the client
the parameter labra cannot talk to each
other do can I use a stronger criterion
because if i have an opponent that is
weaker you can observe less things then
maybe i can transpose more of my actions
and still be found and and we come out
of this as well we we have to break a
poland into two opponents opponent
client an opponent ponent library
parameter library and then we we define
histories where you have this
information in your moves which opponent
is playing and according to the opponent
you play also break player to two
entities and thank you had another
transposition that says well you can
transpose to actions if they happen in
different parts of the of the game if
what happens in the parameter library in
the other in the client and get this an
analogous definition of the capsulation
and again we can show that this
sound and we can also show that he
proved some other examples that
generally know as a build cannot prove
okay so this is all I wanted to talk
about so this work presents the higher
the notion of this correctness criteria
including Lena's ability we provided it
sound more supporters compositional
which said in a social you can also show
that you have the criterion itself is
compositional we respect to library
composition so if you have two libraries
and one limit as the other and you
compose with a third library then you
can show that then the composites
linearized each other as well the pen is
here what we would like to further on
this actually a tu rather stock which
you can have weaker conditions than
linear is ability that for example can
explain or can come from weak memory
models how can we reason about them so
when you do what you're calling first
order linear eyes ability right you have
a proof technique using linearization
points yes here you're not what will be
the linearization points over yes I go
to have these faults no no better ok so
actually uh okay I should have started
the talk by saying that we're new in
this field so we hope we don't I hope
you have not seen anything like
ridiculously wrong but actually when I
we were working on proofs of examples
with it will realize that linearization
put is very important and you can
actually locate them and they happen
between opponent call in dairy and the
response from opponent can be called or
a return again so you have this point
and you can we use them in this in this
proves
yeah yeah I have two questions first one
is some this seems an awful lot like the
conventional notion of vector clocks can
you differentiate this notion of cues
from using vector clocks Michelle
increments in them in the same kind of
way I'm not sure I understand exactly
the questions you mentioned vector clogs
yes how simple question how does this
differ from conventional vector box we
know but maybe have discuss afterwards
that's all so the other time is linear
it's not a distributed system so it's
just a straight line so the partial
orders you see here our interval partial
order so you don't I mean so you're sort
of in a more restricted time domain so
you're not at all you know they don't
need a vector clocks for this stuff yeah
which then begs the question your notion
of time and Hurley he and wings notion
of time was based on a Newtonian
background you know a constant
everywhere irreversible smooth
background um is that something which
you think is justifiable in this day and
age maybe it isn't but we had to start
from somewhere so we started from like
generalizing that's the that word
[Applause]